je vais mettre voir l'ensemble du projet
doit par scrutin public
y at il des demandes d'explication
non pardon à madame benbassa
j'entends pas
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues ce qui s'est passé lors
de la première lecture de ce psg halles
à l'assemblée nationale puis lors de la
cmp à thèse de l'instrumentalisation de
la pandémie de l'aco vide pour faire de
la politique ce qui est une grave erreur
c'est à nous législateurs de ne pas
sacrifier la loi sur l'autel des misères
de la politique politicienne
revenons aux textes cette obligation
vaccinale qui ne dit pas son nom pourra
avoir des effets négatifs à long terme
en le lisant attentivement vient à
l'esprit le titre du livre de foucauld
surveiller et punir pourtant on s'attend
de la part du gouvernement à ceux qui
l'aiment forme convaincre et accompagne
une nouvelle fois l'exécutif cèdent à la
panique et empiète toujours davantage
selon liberté et marginalisent toute une
partie de la population le gouvernement
oublie la prise en compte nécessaire du
caractère international de la lutte
contre l'épidémie une levée des brevets
est indispensable pour démocratiser pour
limiter la circulation des variants même
si pour cela il faudrait arriver à un
accord avec les pays européens et les
états unis vu que nous n'avons pas de
vaccin français pour qu'on puisse lever
par nous mêmes les brevets je reste
persuadé de l'importance est de
l'efficacité du vaccin
son utilisation doit être proportionnée
et rationalisé comme la défenseur des
droits le rappelle dans son dernier avis
je voterai donc contre ce texte merci
merci
madame la présidente est celle ci oui
très rapidement monsieur le président je
les dis dans la discussion générale ce
texte qui instaure un pass vaccinale
après le pass sanitaire est un texte
anachronique et donc il reste
anachronique à l'issue de nos échanges
de cet après midi je ne vais pas revenir
ici alors qu'il est sur les raisons de
fond qui nous font rejeter rejeté ce
texte
mais simplement je regrette que nos
débats de mercredi et de jeudi qui avait
permis l'adoption de plusieurs
amendements qui vais assouplit le texte
dont 4 de notre groupe n'ait pas été
retenue ce qui est quand même réduit
tout cela un compromis politique plus
que déséquilibré entre nous deux ça
semblait donc à l'évidence la droite et
on marche avec le gouvernement sur ce
pass vaccinale que nous rejetons
merci monsieur le questeur sûr
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre chers collègues notre position
a été clair du début à la fin
pour prendre toutes les précautions
sanitaires pour le vaccin qui est une
nécessité
pour le respect des libertés publiques
et il y a eu quelques épisodes qui nous
ont fait craindre malheureusement que le
sénat revienne en arrière
il est bon qu'il soit ferme là dessus
qu'il soit revenu ce matin à une
position plus une position claire pour
nous seules les forces de l'ordre
peuvent
contrôler l'identité et il ne revient
pas aux restaurateurs aux cafetiers au
cinéma aux gérants de cinémas des
documents sportives etc
le faire moyennant quoi nous avons
présenté beaucoup d'amendements 21
exactement aucun n'a été repris
aucun n'a été acceptée alors qu'il y à
des sujets sur lesquels puisque il y
avait pas de nécessité
vous avez renoncé puisque vous avez
renoncé au vote conforme vous étiez
libre d'adopter toutes les 1 certains
nombre de progrès un certain nombre de
points positifs et notamment l'idée
qu'il y ait une date de sortie
par rapport à cette disposition de
passes vaccinale vous est même allé
jusqu'à voter contre
une position qui avait été défendue
écrite par votre notre rapporteur donc
c'est très paradoxal et compte tenu de
cette attitude qui malheureusement n'est
pas aussi positives ou plutôt est plus
négative qu'il eût fallu nous sommes
contraints de nous abstenir sur ce texte
monsieur jomier
merci monsieur près dans madame amis
chers collègues en complément de ce que
vient dire gens bien sûr on se souvient
de l'annnonce de ce texte par le premier
ministre et le message était simple il
faut accélérer la vaccination est donc
on va transformer le pass and i ter en
panne vaccinale est sûre cet objectif
premier nous sommes d'accord et c'est
parce que nous sommes d'accord que nous
avons discuté de ce texte est qu'en
première lecture
constatant que un ensemble de
dispositifs visant à encadrer au mieux
cet outil du pass vaccinale qui nous
satisfait pas vraiment mais enfin bon le
cadrage été correct et bien que la
valeur principe yale qui est celle de
l'obligation vaccinale universel n'y
soit pas comme nous sommes soucieux de
l'intérêt général nous avons
effectivement voté pour ce texte
mais je dois dire que sa trajectoire me
fait penser à ces volatiles qui n'ont
plus peut-être qu'ils partent droit puis
convoi zigzaguer et puis ça fait c
est vraiment on a un texte maintenant
qui a perdu sa cohérence et jusqu'à oui
monsieur le rapporteur on ne peut
qu'être étonné qu'un qu'une disposition
que vous avez fait mettre en première
lecture vous foyer contraint de vous
prononcer contre en seconde lecture je
pense que c'est l'illustration des
errements de ce texte et on ne peut pas
y voir la recherche d'un vote conforme
avec l'assemblée nationale puisqu'il n'y
a pas de vote conforme et donc tout ne
comprenons plus les français ne
comprendront pas non seulement ce texte
est inadaptée à la situation actuelle
mais ils ne se projettent pas dans le
temps et donc pour toutes ces raisons
effectivement nous ne mènerons pas nos
voix à ceux qui sont opposés à la
vaccination
une forme à obstacles
oh c'est bon
votre compte six nations mais nous ne
pourrons pas voter ce texte
monsieur houpert
[Musique]
la parole est à monsieur ou faire madame
la présidente la parole ou perd
seulement
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre chers collègues
mon sentiment c'est que nous venons
d'assister une folie
en tant que parlementaire en tant que
médecin je
citerai le livre d'un moque de stefan
zweig se suffit qu'un médecin un homme
de dévouement d'intuition et de sciences
nous allons voter pour un pass vaccinale
que les pays voisins
quand les pays voisins y renonce et
quand l'épidémie reflux il y à sept pays
qui ont un pass vaccinale donc la france
est 7e sur les 193 qui existe sur cette
planète
et je regrette qu'il n'y ait de monsieur
le feu ce président est monsieur le
président qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'explications de vote sur l'article 1er
peut-être que je n'ai pas été réussi
assez rapide je suis c'est peut-être la
lenteur du sénat le train du sénat et
j'ai ainsi aussi au jeu j'ai assisté
aujourd'hui à des palido ni politique
l'amendement sur les centres commerciaux
avait été adopté par la commission il
était dans la première mouture
c'était pour les français pour que tous
les français les plus sains puisse aller
se servir dans les centres commerciaux
l'art il a retiré et il n'est même pas
voter il rejeter et on a assisté pendant
deux ans à des mensonges et lors de la
première lecture nous avons vu le
ministre déguiser la vérité en
particulier sur le mandant de madame
desks texte clair qui était un bon
amendement sur les tests sérologiques
voilà donc je voterai contre contre
cette loi qui est une loi liberticide on
amine l'une colis aux français une
laisse et à chaque fois on rétrécit la
laisse merci merci monsieur loïc hervé
président madame et messieurs chers
collègues
s'il avait fallu voter mille fois mille
fois j'aurais voté contre le pass
sanitaire elle passe vaccinale si cet
après midi je suis revenu de ma haute
savoie d'élection c'est parce que je
pense à mes enfants je pense à la
société qu'on va leur laisser
et finalement le pass sanitaires et
vaccinales vivre à peu de temps peu de
temps il disparaîtra sans doute mais il
aura été installé instauré l'outil aura
été dit or aura existait dans notre
droit et laissera des traces qu'ils ont
des traces beaucoup plus grave que
l'outil lui-même et c'est pour ça que je
vote contre à nouveau ce soir et c'est
pour ça que même si j'ai pas
l'impression de vivre les plus grandes
heures du parlement français cet après
midi ni d'ailleurs la semaine dernière
j'ai quand même le sentiment que le
sénat père la ligne directrice qui a
toujours été la sienne dans son histoire
c'est ce que j'ai dit dans la question
préalable que j'ai déposée au moment de
dudu de l'examen cette semaine c'est
cette corde raide des libertés publiques
celle qui fait qu'à un moment donné dans
son histoire de ses notes dit stop on
arrête ça va trop loin et finalement
c'est ça notre notre rôle de mon point
de vue et c'est pour ça que au moment où
certains d'entre vous sans doute sans
doute plein de certitudes certain que
c'est fou que se passe vaccinale va
créer des effets forcément très positif
pour le pays et pour l'épidémie mois tel
ignace j'ai beaucoup plus de doutes et
ce soir fort de ce doute méthodologique
je ne m'abstiendrai pas je voterai
contre contre le pass vaccinale contre
pas sanitaire compte toutes ces
nouvelles mesures privatives de liberté
merci
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre aurait d'abord remercié les
rapporteurs les deux présidents de
commission la ministre aussi pour sa
contribution
si on résume dans l'histoire finalement
on aura eu la dépêche dems qui avait
provoqué en 1870 un grave malentendu et
la guerre entre l'allemagne et la france
et cette semaine ils
28-28 jeu sans doute un peu un peu
rapide mais la sphère du tweet
franchement attentatoires attentatoire
aux institutions
qu'elles disent proches qu'elle
disproportion entre ce que peu plus un
tweet et l'effet que cela crée en tout
cas la disproportion entre ce tweet et
l'enjeu sanitaire je me félicite que
notre majorité nous votre en très
majoritairement une fois de plus pour ce
texte et nous avons tenu notre ligne une
ligne à la fois de responsabilité mais
aussi une ligne d'exigence
responsabilités nous disons oui au passe
parce que nous voulons inciter les
français à la vaccination
les choses sont absolument claires pour
nous même si nous pensons pas que le
pass vaccinale soit l'alpha et l'oméga
notamment sur la crise parce que il y
aura un décalage temporel plusieurs
d'entre nous l'ont déjà souligné mais
nous apportons une contribution à la
lutte contre le virus l'exigence c'est
tout simplement que lorsque l'assemblée
s'était éloigné des positions du sénat
nous avions tenu à rappeler un certain
nombre de points sur les amants sur ce
régime administratif qui vient
sanctionner les entreprises chantal de
scène nous a souvent précisé que lors
des enquêtes par l'administration se
lance 0,7 37% des entreprises avait été
prise en défaut pour coller pointé du
doigt idem sur le contrôle d'identité
à vis des cafetiers et c'est donc voilà
nous voterons très majoritairement merci
à notre assemblée d'ailleurs depuis le
départ sur ce texte d'avoir tenu des
débats je trouve serein calme et de
qualité
dernière explication de vote monsieur le
président marseille
merci monsieur non mais attendez s'il y
en a d'autres qui veulent s'exprimer
faites-le d'un coup parce que mercy du
mal à vous à ce sera la dernière
madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le président madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales à mon tour je voudrais
remercier le rapporteur et madame le
rapporteur pour avis les présidents des
commissions
pour leur travail et leur implication
notre groupe lui aussi dans sa grande
majorité votera le texte on aurait pu
cela a déjà été dit s'épargner les
palinodies de la cmp on peut pas comme
l'a fait monsieur virant à longueur de
journée nous expliquer qu'on ne peut pas
opérer les gens qu'il faut attendre que
les
personnels de santé n'en peuvent plus
que les hôpitaux sont au bord de la
rupture et prendre son temps comme si
nous pouvions encore passer plusieurs
jours plusieurs semaines à discuter
cela pourtant a été fait c'est la raison
pour laquelle maintenant sans attendre
je crois qu'il faut tourner la page et
passer à autre chose il serait bon
d'ailleurs que comme cela était
souhaitée dans un passé récent nous
puissions rediscuter de l'évolution de
la maladie parce que le sénat lui peut
continuer à se réunir à tout moment et
même l'assemblée si elle était convoqué
parce qu'on voit bien qu'il ya des
évolutions
nous avons voté l'urgence sanitaire nous
avons été le pass sanitaire nous votons
le pass vaccinale mais pas interdit de
réfléchir comme le font les
scientifiques sur l'évolution de la
maladie et il serait peut-être bon qui
est une revoyure si le gouvernement elle
pouvait mettre cet ordre du jour assez
rapidement pour voir ce qu'il en advient
dans les semaines qui viennent
j'ajouterai enfin qu'il ya un point qui
ne figure pas dans le texte et il est
important c'est la raison pour laquelle
mon collègue bonnecarrère a déposé une
ppl haut ce sont les conditions
d'exercice de la démocratie pour le vote
à l'élection présidentielle et pour les
élections législatives
nous n'avons rien dans ce texte si la
maladie perdure ou si elle s'amplifier
nous n'avons rien qui est prévu pour que
les gens puissent voter en toute
sécurité en toute tranquillité c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons déposé
c'était que je vous remercie d monsieur
breda enfin madame jasmin
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre vous constatez aujourd'hui qui
a un véritable échec l'échec de la
vaccination
l'échec de la méthodologie et dépôts ses
yeux qui ont été mises en oeuvre c'est
vrai que le mot d'ordre est désormais la
vaccination permet
d'avoir des formes moins grave jeudi les
empêche d'aller en réanimation mais une
vaccination une réelle vaccination
permet d'avoir surtout des anticorps
pour résister des anticorps et
malheureusement la politique qui a été
menée jusqu'à maintenant à occulter la
vraie immunité
c'est ça alors je ne vais pas à dire
comment j'avais voté vous savez très
bien que jamais les mêmes votre colis
fait la dernière fois lors de la
première lecture mais je dis que nous
devons aujourd'hui
soignée d'abord soignés soigner
permettre aux médecins traitants que je
le disais les médecins traitants qui
avait été occultée et bien aujourd'hui
permettre aux médecins de faire leur
travail est la dernière chose que je
dirais également en juillet dernier
j'avais pris position avait dit 3e 4e
peut-être cinquième roue on en est
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas que j'avais
raison mais le constat est là dans nos
beaucoup d'hommes nombreux collègues et
le nombreuses collègues ont demandé des
rapports aujourd'hui c'est l'heure de
faire le bilan de cet échec et je dirais
enfin monsieur le président que madame
la ministre au magic dernier je disais
également qu'en guadeloupe et finalement
il y avait beaucoup de personnes qui
n'étaient pas vaccinés et ce n'est pas
pour les excuser mais je disais
également que beaucoup de guadeloupéens
vont dérouler deux vaccins qui ne soit
pas un vaccin arn messagers aujourd'hui
et bientôt ce sera le cas et je crois
que beaucoup de mes compatriotes vont se
faire vacciner pour savoir en temps de
la population fera savoir entendre et
comprendre surtout lorsqu'on est ici on
représente les territoires et je
souhaiterais vraiment que désormais les
mesures qui seront prises seront au
faveur de l'égalité de la population je
vois merci merci
j'ai été saisi d'une demande d'un
scrutin public par les groupes
socialistes écologistes et républicains
par le groupe crc eux par le groupe
l'est républicain
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
17h40
19h47 sur public sénat on touche à la
fin de cet examen pour ce deuxième
lecture de l'examen du texte sur le pass
vaccinale un scrutin public a été
demandée ce qui veut dire que dans
quelques instants on connaîtra et bien
la position de chaque sénateur de chaque
groupe politique sur l'ensemble de ce
texte soumis par le gouvernement aux
deux assemblées on a déjà un peu une
petite idée puisque on a entendu les
explications de vote petite surprise
avec les socialistes qui avaient voté
majoritairement pour ce texte en
première lecture et qui dont vous l'avez
entendu vont s'abstenir sur 7 sur ce
texte qui donc revient après l'examen
l'adoption par les députés à l'assemblée
nationale hier soit abstention donc des
socialistes sur ce texte et socialistes
qui reproche notamment à la majorité
sénatoriale de ne pas avoir introduit de
nouvelles jauges pour l'augmenter pour
encadrer ce pass vaccinale souhaité par
le gouvernement le scrutin est
maintenant terminée on va écouter les
résultats de ce scrutin public
sur l'ensemble du texte contenu de
l'ensemble des délégations de vote
accordés par les sénateurs au politique
est notifié la présidence nombre de
votants 341 nombre de suffrages exprimés
253 pour l'adoption 187 contre 66 le
sénat a adopté
mais cher collègue madame la ministre
mesdames et messieurs les présidents je
vais lever la séance prochaines séances
le mardi 18 janvier à 9h30 pour les
questions orales la séance est levée
[Musique]